reading about the two of you your fans
seem very like your fans
really sweet and they kind of take a
real interest in your life
that they come up like they come up to
you and
it's sweet they talk to you like they
know you yes they give me love advice
they give me you know yeah robert's fans
they seem more nuts
no offense
because they're quite some of them are
quite out there
yeah i mean i think they just like uh
[Music]
i mean
i think you get it i have a much more
simplistic reaction with fans that i
think like it's like you know
i i i it's like screaming and so it's
kind of
and so it limits it i think you get
because like you know when we've been
doing these with these premieres and
stuff there's like an overwhelming
amount of energy and i think it's
because if this everyone's just trying
to do the same thing they've only got
one thing to say
like which is just
screaming and you can just like really
focus all your energy together and it's
like it's really powerful
it's like uh excalibur
or the captain planet or something
i was going up to a screaming girl and
freaking her out by going hi what's your
name
i've always wanted to do a sketch for
some comedy show where i'd
go down you know you better premiere
with everybody screaming and uh
go back to the sort of dungeon place and
then you have all these fans locked up
on this like german techno meeting just
scream at them
how many golf and like zac efron's at
the top of the stairs going in next or
something like that
they didn't let me do it
i had a sort of long-standing affair
with a guerrilla called zaire about 10
years ago and um she's
a lovely lovely gorilla and
we hung out for it for a couple of
months i was observing her and we got to
you know play games and sort of you know
with each other and it was all rather
lovely and then and then and then one
way about two months
but but lorraine my wife came down to
visit i said you've got to come down and
meet zayn and
and when when she came down literally
got this bottle of water which has
minerals in and and vitamins and she
just went like that and squirted squeeze
it right right in lorraine's face that's
what she did to me yeah
but they do they get so protective they
really do yeah yeah and territorial oh
you're talking about monkeys again okay
the other thing that chimpanzees do of
course is a thing called pant hooting
which is
[Applause]
when do chimps do that
when they're very excited
is that a happy thing or a sad thing
it's a kind of no it's it's a kind of
territorial thing other kind of and it's
quite scary
yeah it's defending territory okay i
feel like i've heard that sound yeah
all right i'm sure you have sienna
the thing is it is a sofa of actors so
uh andy
are there kind of any i wouldn't say
tricks but are there any shortcuts into
playing a a great ape
a great eight um well um
well well
quadrupeding is a large part of it okay
so quadrupeding is walking on all fours
and uh
i happen to have with me some um
some arm extensions which we could we
could all have a go with all right and
these in fact are
how we quadrupled so we can all have a
go and i think i think we should would
you like to have a go no not yet
let me just show you so these are these
are looking it's got
motion capture dots on it already so so
we can shoot um so anyway so you so let
me just uh
is this a good place to stand in this
yeah
or wherever
wherever you want to go yeah so first of
all you know if you're going to get into
into being an eight lucky like um if
you're a silverback gorilla then you
tend to have your backside stealing out
if you're if you're chimpanzee then you
then you're tucked in like this so you
can choose between a gorilla or an
origin pencil whichever you'd like yeah
[Applause]
shoes on but
i'd like that so
wow that's very impressive
this is for a roller coaster
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm glad i wore such tight trousers
how do you beat your chest with these
things yeah that's a tough one so hang
on gorilla is the archers
[Applause]
oh
as a chimp
[Applause]
but colin farrell beautiful right
beautiful man
you're a beautiful man thank you for
recognizing the distinction you are no
you're
beautiful okay hey graeme get a room
i'm in it
was a ruse
no but i feel though colin sometimes i
feel too great you you fight your own
beauty you fight your beauty and you
often use the medium of hair to fight
your way i've had some of the worst
hairdos in film do you really have yeah
no genuine like a vampire magazine did
top 10 worst hairdos in film i'm
definitely
three of those
you know sometimes you're intentional
like horrible bosses is intentional and
that's
that wasn't one of the three i was
talking about
seriously but a movie i love home at the
end of the world oh thanks uh it's just
such a good movie and you're so good in
it however
that's how we hampered i feel like oh
yeah
i mean that's a testament to what a mess
i was at the time that i actually stood
in front of a camera with that in my
head
i believe i've gone to dinner with her
[Applause]
but then i think the most famous is of
course this one in alexander
which
there's worse pictures than that from
alexander that's actually not bad that
was my dars day look yeah because you're
so not a blonde i mean it did seem a big
decision to make or was alexander
famously blonde he was famously blondie
a golden lock to golden lock child but
he shouldn't have been he should have
been brunette
for sure maybe you shouldn't have had an
irish accent
only from the 7000 reviews i read
everyone has an opinion
[Music]
you